the market's
gone wild game stop up another 130
percent today
it's like the villagers storming the
castle there's something remarkable but
watching uh
watching the little guy beat the big guy
investors are getting very nervous about
the speculation
that is going on surrounding gamestop uh
and wondering whether we're in a
speculative bubble that is soon to burst
this will end in tears you know gamestop
is not worth 500 it's not worth for you
not worth through not work towards not
even worth a hundred it's not even worth
50.
i don't know what the hell it's worth
and other people make a lot of money and
i saw it in the past
i'm gonna level with you i have no idea
what most of that means
what i've gathered so far is that some
very rich hedge fund investors made a
bet
against some very big stocks like
gamestop and
amc theaters which have been struggling
during the pandemic
an enterprising army of day traders with
reddit accounts
is making those big investors lose their
shirts
in three weeks game stops gamestop stock
as a mouthful
has gone from being worth less than 18 a
share
to closing as high as 350
and now wall street is going berserk
over everyday joes
fueling a possible stock bubble congress
is already planning hearings on
hedge funds internet brokers and the
practices that got us here
the online shard and freuda is flowing
like water
and the memes are glorious yeah
what's really happening i don't really
understand this story
so i ask my kids and who do they go to
when they don't understand something
especially something involving
numbers they go to khan academy whose
founder educator sal khan
also happens to have degrees from mit
and harvard and once worked
as an analyst at a hedge fund he joins
me now sal thanks so much for coming on
the show there's a lot to cover here
but first can you briefly explain to our
viewers what hedge funds are
and what it means for them to short a
stock and then we'll talk about gamestop
yeah good question i remember even the
first time when i was applying for a job
at a hedge fund i asked a friend so what
exactly is a hedge fund
good to know before i go into the
interview but put simply it's
it's an asset manager it's an investment
firm but it has more flexibility than
say a mutual fund which is heavily
regulated
now that flexibility could be used to do
very legitimate things and sometimes
take on
less risk but they can do things like
short stocks which they'll talk about
they can buy
options they can buy other types of more
exotic securities
and because they're less regulated
they're allowed to market or they're not
allowed to market at all or there's a
more narrow class of people that can
invest in them
so so when we talk about uh hedge fund
shorting
shorting game stock game shops kind of
mistaken word
when we talk about them shorting the
stock what does that mean
so very simple a short is a bet that the
stock will go down
now the way that it works is the whoever
the investor is
uh or whoever wants to short the stock
they need to borrow
the stock from someone who owns the
stock and then they borrow it
they sell it and then at a future date
when they have to pay back
the stock they have to buy it back so
normally you buy a stock
hopefully you buy low and then later you
sell high and you make a profit that way
a shorter does it the other way around
they're going to sell
high now and then the way that they
would make money is if the stock price
gets lower and then they can buy it
later and i know it's very
counterintuitive to think about
borrowing stock so one analogy is
imagine you had a car sitting in your
driveway and i knew you weren't going to
use it for the next
six months and i go hey can i borrow
your car
for the next six months and i won't even
drive it and you say sure
and then i borrow your car i sell it
let's say for ten thousand dollars
and then six months later when you're
like hey sal where was my car i was like
oh yeah i'll get it for you
and then i buy an identical car with
identical mileage for say eight thousand
dollars and i returned the car to you
and i just made two thousand dollars on
that on that depreciation
this is essentially what people are
doing with stocks okay
so they're doing it with stocks hedge
funds are doing what they do what
they've always done they're shorting the
stock on gamestop or amc
where does this reddit forum wall street
bets and the online brokerages like
robin hood that we're hearing about
where does that come into how is that
called such a controversy right now
so what's interesting about shorting and
you know i know it's a very
controversial thing but there's
legitimate reasons why someone might
want to short it might hedge
their risk if they're investing in other
similar companies to kind of hedge out
market risk it could be a way it's
actually good for the market to help
discover prices it gives an incentive
for people to discover
shady things that might be happening at
a company or things like that but
shorting is inherently very risky
because if i
sell something at let's say ten dollars
a share i can make i can
at maximum make ten dollars if that
share price would go to zero but i could
lose an infinite amount if that share
price goes to a hundred dollars i'll
lose ninety dollars on a
ten dollar bet if it goes to a thousand
dollars i'll lose nine hundred ninety
ninety dollars and so you can imagine a
lot of game stop
was a very shorted stock uh because of
the overall market because of
you know very few people are going and
buying physically video games and
in malls anymore and so it was heavily
shorted by these hedge funds so a lot of
the stock out there was borrowed
and sold ahead of time now a lot of
these reddit users said hey
why don't we buy that stock and i think
they were trying to create what's called
a
short squeeze and what this is is as the
stock price starts to go up
some of these hedge funds that had
shorted it have kind of weak hands
and so as the price goes up and they
start to lose money their brokerages
their prime brokers for the hedge funds
will say hey
you have a losing position here we need
you to unwind your position
and so those hedge funds have to take a
loss and when they unwind their position
they now have to buy the stock that they
had previously sold
and then that drives up the price even
more and then other hedge funds are
gonna have to do that
price goes up even more simultaneously
you have an army of people on reddit
who are trying to buy as much of the
stock as possible that's only
accelerating that short squeeze behavior
yeah and the hedge funds are not used to
kind of everyday joes doing this to them
and causing them billions of dollars in
losses
they're used to buying the car back at
8k and pocketing the difference
they're not they're not used to this so
let's just talk about
uh robin hood which is this brokerage
which sold itself
as a kind of you know every man's friend
you know democratizing finance
everyone can buy stocks today they're
people are up in arms because they
suspended
uh people from allowing you know getting
into this uh gamestop stock people say
well you're taking the side of the hedge
funds
have a listen have a listen to the guy
from uh the head the ceo of robin hood
who spoke on cnbc earlier today
so we're really in unprecedented times
and
in order to protect the firm and protect
our customers
we had to limit buying in these in these
stocks
what do you make of those comments yeah
you know i've been reading into this
uh i haven't found a really good reason
why they needed to do that
other than to potentially protect people
where they're actually making their
revenue
you know robin hood famously has zero
commission trades they need to make
their money someplace
one of the places that they make money
is by lending shares to people who might
want to short it there might be other
ways that
we don't fully understand on how they
make their money but i see
you know they're more than happy
allowing people to buy and sell and day
trade and whatever else that's really
what their clientele is based on
and now all of a sudden when people want
to buy this one stock it does seem
suspicious
uh that now all of a sudden they're
getting into the game of of
protection you know at the end of the
day if the hedge funds want to do
something like shorting the ultimate
kind of balancing on that is allowing
every now and then for them to lose
their shirts when they when a bet goes
wrong
that is going to sober up the hedge fund
community going forward it's a natural
it's natural selection in the hedge fund
community and so
it does look suspicious when a brokerage
firm is stopping people from buying it
what it looks like is to protect the
short squeeze from happening further
and if and of course i should point out
that a lot of those users have banded
together
to sue robin hood for blocking their
trades today so there's going to be
a lot more on this story i mean
personally i think robin hood may be
thinking about renaming themselves the
name
doesn't really help them on a day like
today uh one last question sal
tyler winklevoss the mega investor
famous for suing
uh facebook founder mark zuckerberg he
tweeted this he said what kind of
soulless human being
do you have to be to short brick and
mortar businesses during a pandemic
when these companies are not even
allowed to legally operate these suits
have no solidarity they care nothing
about america i'm glad
wall street bets is punching back he has
a point doesn't he
i mean in the mortgage bubble that
caused the great recession fortunes were
made
betting against americans being able to
pay off their home loans
and hedge funds are doing something
similar today aren't they
yeah well you know our financial system
is really complex and i do think and i'm
i'm out of the hedge fund world now but
there are legitimate reasons why you
would want to short it helps
price discovery allows assets to be
allocated appropriately
but i do think you know when you go back
to the mortgage crisis there was
shadiness in the financial system it was
actually much more around
how mortgages were packages packaged and
sliced and diced and then sold to
investors in maybe
misrepresented ways towards ratings
agencies that were a little bit shady
at that at that phase but i think this
is a situation where the ultimate
punishment is to let the short squeeze
happen
so that in the future people are going
to be a lot more careful shorting stocks
yeah this story is not going away it's
fascinating as it is complicated for
some of us who are not finance people
sal khan appreciate you coming on and
helping us make sense of it thanks so
much
for your time tonight
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe
below to stay up to date on the day's
biggest stories thank you for watching